hello and welcome to this video playing
you jes less okay so um Sicilian should
be fine
okay go g6e em that's what I have
basically always played he's playing my
own repertoire against me you thought if
he had this knight f6 an 85mm 4 is odd
not quite sure what is supposed to do
maybe securing the bishop when you
intend to put it onto C form don't know
that looks very comfortable for me
I got f5 and he's got no porn break
let's do it right away
yeah it's a nice Center to have with
black yeah it's a kind of move if you
don't do that it's kind of questionable
if you're not just getting steamrolled
at self I kind of understand why why is
conveyors coming from but it shows that
things have gone seriously wrong for
white thing is I can probably even keep
the pawn with Knight to g6 it's not
really other than you need to I mean
these pieces are so messed up
okay let's see what he does Knight f3
yeah okay here here knight c6 looks like
the most obvious choice but maybe he
will check me and then play Knight to d5
then take on f4
you know I still promise that's correct
didn't expect that
hmm what do I do now I wonder if and
there should be five looks like a
strange move a Kim I'm just going to
return that I mean but that then white
is better that's strange
it doesn't take it
didn't take it
though I'm always imitated if I have a
hard time to ever get the move them
especially if they don't play the most
natural moves which you normally just do
in a blitz game
I gained a bit of space but it's still
not an easy situation I have to be
careful about ninety five stuff
happening like 2795 think it works but
and then it's got 95 okay let's go 37 if
there is if it doesn't work energy five
and okay it goes here okay
hmm okay f3 is an idea but I have to
stop you 6 first I think
thinking all chief fire
not sure if that was as if that is a
good idea rook g5 but G file mmm cut
some some play there
and he's not speeding up I mean not at
all okay maybe I can just go for four
tactics with him being low on time Queen
age three is on the cards goes goes H
four okay
okay of three if the maid thread and
queen age three
yeah I know it wasn't such a weird game
and yeah it's always tough to say have
you seen such a profile he's only got
some blitz games in and yeah you never
know
there were so many weird moves that I
had some brief suspicion that I could be
a computer of it it wasn't of the same
um okay and because I can most like me
who plays ha4
or it just said so odd
what is this old sequence him then like
95 didn't go Bishop c4 which looks very
natural or here like why not taking
place c3 I mean I mean I would just take
on a form
how can covers b2 but I would never take
that yeah I know I was irritated somehow
it obviously wasn't an engine but during
the game I wasn't sure
so t4
you know I just blend the c5 here okay
didn't know I'm better right
rook to e8 is better oh yeah FFF 3 I
wasn't really a certain down if this is
this is a move I was thinking maybe even
g4 is going to happen but yeah I saw I
saw I'm sorry I saw that I cannot go him
and then I wasn't sure I never take
something like that I'm not sure if I'm
winning the engine points out a pretty
huge advantage but
yes oh look a five that is not a good
choice h4 is stronger yeah and it seems
that this didn't work he found good
before which is so good but it's it's
winning in multiple ways I was a bit
playing on the time situation of course
now Queen f5 was a blunder finally he's
winning in multiple ways but he didn't
have any time so I was a lucky winner
yeah apologize for mentioning the
possibility that white was cheating it
was just like the combination of
fishy-looking account yeah it's just
like those no no nothing then then just
a couple of blitz games and then a
couple of moves that genuinely seemed
weird to me that is some yeah it just
happens so often that you you think
about it okay thanks a lot for watching